[Musique]
où
bonjour et bienvenue à tous bienvenue on
est aujourd'hui en direct est très
heureux de vous retrouver avec mes dit
bonjour mehdi hop là je m'attends qui
n'ont ici mehdi qui est responsable
marketing de bosses france exactement je
suis monsieur greuet l'on retrouve
aujourd'hui en direct à la fois sur le
site de la fnac et fnac.com pour venir
parler de bosses edgar parler du nouveau
qc 45 qu'on a avec nous alors on va tout
vous dire on va passer un petit moment
ensemble donc soyez tranquilles on a le
temps on va échanger ensemble on va
répondre également à vos questions je me
les petits textes comme ça en dessous
vous savez tout s'arrête très sympa non
dans convivial à passer ensemble sur ces
deux plateformes donc soyez les
bienvenus si vous venez d'arriver et
puis on passe un petit mouvement
ensemble parce que tu es prêt mais dit
tout à fait prêt je te sens est parti je
te sang chaud patate tout simplement je
suis chaud chaud j'aime bravo à les gens
aiment ça alors on va tout d'abord va
venir parler un petit peu de bosses
parce que bombe aux cetc une marque on
connaît tous on a peut-être déjà eu des
produits de base ou alors on connaît des
gens qui ont des produits bosal sorbonne
moi je connais beaucoup à travers
forcément les casques mais ya pas que
des casques est ce que me dit tu peux
leur parler un petit peu de buzz
exactement alors déjà j'ai une petite
question pour toi ouais bof c'est qu'à
l'origine pour toi
bose
je ne sais pas japd anglo saxons ouais
ouais un peu plus précis tu as une idée
mais je n'aime pas les pièces comme ça
écoute je peux te dire que c'est sur
c'est fichtrement rien alors c'est une
marque américaine c'est une marque
américaine active j'ai pas osé le dire
mais je les pense être
on y va sans mais crée effectivement par
le docteur amar bronze en 1964 que dit
docteur et oui doctorants docteurs en
quoi alors ingénieur en électronique des
enseignants ou et mighty donc quand même
produire ya du niveau il ya de la
trompette du gros niveau et
effectivement il s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait énormément de choses à
faire à développer
au niveau de niveau de l'audio et il a
une idée justement de créer la marque
bose pour proposer au grand public d'une
audio premium hockey et a beaucoup
travaillé notamment sur les effets de
spatialisation au tout début pour
arriver à des produits qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui donc les casques et tuent
par les différentes catégories c'est
vrai que vaut ce n'est pas uniquement
des casques c'est également des
écouteurs on a aussi de la barre de son
mât d'enceinte tous à tous ces produits
forment un écosystème aujourd'hui dans
la gamme et aujourd'hui je suis ravi
d'être ici pour parler du remplaçant du
nikon oued une icône le q7 de cusset 35
exactement qui était effectivement une
référence sur le marché au niveau de la
qualité sonore très très bon réduction
de bruit il donc là il ya son son petit
seconde main son petit frère son grand
frère sont entre successeurs sont comme
on l'appelle le grand frère donc le cul
c'est 45 couette confort 45 wyeth
confort 45 exacte non c'est un donjon
c'est bien de dire que tu sais 45 j'aime
bien que ça marche et puis je pense que
pour les gens n'y a pas mal qui permet
de gens qui se réfère à ce produit sous
qc
partant là dessus et ben écoute moi ça
me va très bien alors on va en profiter
très très rapidement pour saluer un peu
tout le monde qui arrivait dans le tchat
sur ma chaîne youtube vous êtes
également nombreux à être présents et
bien sûr le site de la fnac on va se
faire une session de questions réponses
justes à la fin pendant ce temps si vous
avez des questions à poser soit vous
bien dans un coin de votre tête soit
vous noté sur un papier ou alors si vous
pouvez pas attendre vous les mettez dans
le tchat on vous répondra bien
évidemment vont en profiter pour saluer
un petit peu tout le monde je regarde
vous êtes nombreux nombreux nombreux à
être à être présent et à avoir répondu à
l'appel de bosses du qu c 45 donc très
très cool je voudrais une fois de plus
noté toutes vos questions on en
reparlera je regarde un petit peu les
messages bonjour à tous à lui voilà
gayet du monde combien de temps dure la
présentation au nom de laurent écoute
laurent je pense qu'on est là pour 30 35
minutes plus si affinités on a des
choses à voir ensemble on va prendre un
petit peu de temps on va regarder tous
les points ensemble avec mehdi parce que
on est là pour comprendre et découvrir
ce ce nouveau qc 45 alors et répondre
aux questions il répondre aux questions
donc session de questions réponses à la
fin bien évidemment alors moi je
voudrais qu'on regarde déjà un petit peu
ce un petit peu ce cas ce qu'a tenté de
mettre la caméra du dessus ça c'est
l'emballage
ok on va là on y reviendra à l'emballage
est ce que tu peux nous montrer le
casque pour qu'on le voit alors on a la
chance ici d'avoir les deux couleurs
disponibles hyper canon donc le black et
laure heitz moque donc gloire et blanc
alors mon premier ressenti
c'est par rapport aux puces et 35 tu vas
que ses 35 ans non non ok je te demande
pardon
je t'ai vu je t'ai vu avec un autre
produit un jeu acheté 700 jlec jeu mais
je l'avais déjà été piquouse et n'ont
jamais avec les dissidents j'ai des
choses de bosses mais le qg 35 qui ne
l'est pas mais gardons malheureuse qui
cite si bon pour ce qui est celle qui
avait déjà accusé 35 voix elle est quand
même sur un design qui reste très proche
qui a fait ses preuves comme je le
disais alors c'est une icône qui est un
qui vient ce qui vient de remplacer du
coup il avait fait ses preuves en termes
de confort il reste une référence le cul
c'est 35 et ce confort dans le gard
notamment ce que je vois je rentre au
paraguay
[Musique]
non je n'ai pas senti en termes de oui
le confort c'était déjà une référence
voilée on est venus améliorer encore cet
aspect là donc
le premier truc qu'on peut voir et qu'on
peut ressentir dans les premiers essais
moi je peux te le dire - e
quand je les ouvert que je les prie en
main j'ai trouvé très léger et j'ai
beaucoup aimé ce côté effectivement
légèreté au dessus dias et
c'est très léger pour un trio de gamme
et en fait c'est si génial parce que
lorsque vous le mettez je chante en plus
elle me parle pas lorsque vous le mettez
comme ça sur votre tête on a vraiment le
confort au niveau des coussinets mais ça
tu vas nous en reparler donc il ya
vraiment ce côté tout de suite légèreté
qui vient vraiment frappé et que je
trouve vraiment super ah ouais bon pour
être un peu technique en option après
extrêmement léger de 138 g way pour le
casque
l'avantagent sait qui en fait on est sur
un produit on va dire lifestyle donc le
but c'est de le porter tous les jours
quelles que soient les situations et
l'avantagé c'est qu'en fait il ya un
effet d'invisibilité je portais des
heures et on est absolument pas gêné
c'est extrêmement confortable c'est
quand même très appréciable la deuxième
chose c'est effectivement amélioré donc
la partie arceaux le montre sur le
monsieur loyal
partir ses deux parties are ceux-là qui
est beaucoup plus souple encore ce qui
participe grandement au confort de prise
en main et au niveau du portet
et alors je sais pas pour toi mais moi
je prends le casque quand je vais quand
je vais bosser ouais je suis quand dans
les transports je prends l'avion et dieu
sait que c'est extrêmement intéressant
d'avoir un produit complet on peut
porter pendant des heures sans être gêné
oui parce que sinon ça peut être
carrément embêtant c'est hyper important
d'avoir du confort avec un casque comme
ça c'est ce qu'on vient chercher sur un
produit comme celui là on parle quand
même du premium on est sur le flagship
de bose aujourd'hui que ce produit là le
nouveau qc 45 exactement alors on a une
gamme qui est qui se complètent oui mais
effectivement on est sur des produits
premium et tout ce qui va avec du coup
ok donc moi je veux que tu me parles d
des matériaux parce que je vois
effectivement que l'âge et au son des
petites caméras du dessus je vois qu
effectivement là j'ai un côté un peu en
étant les bras j'ai un côté très très
très très molletonné donc qui vient
vraiment accueillir la tête et surtout
pour s'adapter à toutes les formes de
crâne alors moi je n'ai pas utilisé
pendant des heures donc je n'ai pas
aujourd'hui le retour sur les points de
pression et ce genre de choses mais en
tout cas ce que je peux voir là c'est
qu'il ya quelque chose de très
confortables et ça c'est plutôt agréable
je vois effectivement aussi que j'ai des
coussinets qui sont enveloppants et très
très confortable ce qui fait que lorsque
je l'aimais la gauche droite c'est comme
ça en terme d'accueil ils viennent bien
épouser la forme de mes oreilles j'ai
une sensation d'avoir un casque léger
sur la tête donc ça ça me plaît beaucoup
sur ça vraiment intéressant je l'enlève
parce que sinon j'entends absolument
rien elle la réduction de bruit active
on en parle dans quelques instants donc
ça c'est cool alors j'ai pris quelques
petites notes j'ai noté nylon renforcé à
la fibre de verre ouais ça ça vient
jouer sur la résistance en fait du
matériau bah écoutes je te laisse oui on
va toujours way dit davantage c'est que
tu peux le plier comme tu veux en fait
c'est assez édifiant il âgé aucun risque
de casser ont le temps d'antenne si tu
fais y aller je peux y aller t'inquiète
pas ok ça c'est le premier avantage donc
évidemment matériaux de qualité qui
permettent une durabilité dans le temps
va plus c'est très appréciable et comme
tu l'as dis donc on est sur des sur des
matières en l'occurrence en simili cuir
et vous dites cuir synthétique qui fait
chanter c'est du cuir mais ce n'est pas
du cuir mais il ya un aspect cuir et qui
donne ce côté premium avec un bémol
tenait exactement exactement ça c'est
très très cool alors je voudrais que tu
montes un peu plus le produit parce que
là on parle effectivement et bien des
des matériaux on voit qu'il ya des
boutons sur ce produit notamment alors
hop là ils sont situés là alors il faut
vraiment savoir que là vous avez loupé
leur l'écouteur gauche pardon l'écouteur
droit donc à l'arrière se situent des
boutons est ce que tu peux me raconter
des choses un peu sur ses boutons dit
s'il te plaît aujourd'hui enfin on a
écouté nos clients comme comme je le
disais le cul c'est 35 reste une icône
chez nous est un des éléments qui
ressortait le plus souvent c'est sa
simplicité d'utilisation et les boutons
malgré tout reste un facteur de
simplicité quand tu compare à des
technologies tactiles par exemple donc
pour ceux qui ces 45 on est resté sur ce
système à boutons avec donc le réglage
des volumes le réglage de la réduction
de bruit le marche arrêt et la connexion
bluetooth d'accord ok extrêmement simple
prise en main
enfantine donc que des avantages là
dessus ouais après sur d'autres produits
de la gamme notamment le hp 700 on est
sur des réglages tactile mais on est sur
deux produits avec des usages
complètement différent au sein de la
gamme aux enfants comment est ce que tu
viens les situer ces deux produits tu me
dis qu'on a des usages différents mais
c'est qu'on veut dire et comme ça agace
c'est très bête en ce que je vais dire
un très basique un casse c'est un cas
c'était pour écouter de la musique donc
tu me dis des usages différents non
c'est alors effectivement c'est écouter
la musique reste un des usages white hot
a tout à fait sur ce que ces 45 sur
cette gamme là ouais on va être sur un
produit usage au quotidien lifestyle
simplicité confort avec la réduction de
bruit pose qui est aujourd'hui une des
meilleures si ce n'est la meilleure
pourrait
alors que sur 1 h et 700 on va être sur
un usage beaucoup plus spécifique avec
des réglages plus fins ok sur certaines
choses pour des usages plus variés
hockey comme par exemple le télétravail
qui aujourd'hui mouais
c'est dans le quotidien des gens le hp
700 avec son réglages plus fins des
micro permet pour ce genre spécifiques
d'utilisation d'avoir un confort maximum
sur une utilisation de tous les jours
oui pour écouter sa musique prendre ses
appels
le cul c'est 45 et aujourd'hui notre
notre produit star d'accord et et on a
énormément de gens qui sont à la
recherche qui sont toujours à la
recherche de ce type de produits donc en
termes de polyvalence on parle plus du
qu c 45 aujourd'hui peut-être c'est moi
j'ai tout compris au maire si beaucoup
mais ok donc ça c'est bien on voit
qu'effectivement pour le connecter pour
venir la paire est un smartphone c'est
très facile compatible bien évidemment à
ios mais également android donc ça c'est
vachement agréable et puis je voudrais
qu'on parle un petit peu de l'expérience
au niveau de l'étude on bat jonathan va
faire place belle ici on va retirer aux
produits ça c'est la boîte alors la
boîte je le mets bien j'aime bien moi
quand je les récupérer la boîte était
comme ça le seul petit truc que je veux
me reprocher cette boîte c'est que ici
vous avez une petite ouverture facile et
rapide vous venez vous des zips et ça
s'ouvre et ça peut plus jamais se
refermer alors moi qui suis un petit
garçon qui aime bien
j'aime bien regarder les boîtes voilà
donc je peux le garder mais il va venir
me chanter des chansons comme ça
néanmoins à l'intérieur je te laisse et
l'ouvrir ça c'est devant toi ça sera
beaucoup plus simple au niveau de la
manipulation il vient s'ouvrir comme ça
et là on découvre l'étui dans lequel on
vient à angers sont pucées 45 alors
évidemment c'est vite parce que on s'est
fait plaisir avant c'est pas faux on at
on appris le casque on s'est fait
plaisir alors qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve à
l'intérieur alors donc tu as évidemment
non montrant que ces 35 45 45 kw alliés
comme comme je vais montrer tout à
l'heure avec son espace dédié ça c'est
des petites protection leptine ouest qui
viennent avec un exactement ok tu as
toute la partie usb ces partis
chargement ouais donc on est en usb c&cu
sbc usb attends je n'ai pas ouvert mois
elle devrait d'accord donc ça c'est de
l'usbc usb à on va se parler d'autonomie
on va se parler de charge dans quelques
instants j'ai vu qu'il ya des questions
qui sont arrivés injustement sur sur la
sur la charge sur tout ça sur
l'autonomie donc on va en parler dans
quelques instants donc regarder ça c'est
au plat voilà usb usb c'est ok qu'est ce
qu'on a ensuite médias l'intérieur
autres petits cadeaux à j'aime quand on
parle de câbles un câble jack classique
pour
l'écouter donc en tournée meilleure
prédiction
pour ce pur lorsqu'on a besoin d'avoir
une simple connexion jack quand ça lui
permet d'ailleurs puisque tous les
appareils ne le permettent pas
aujourd'hui ouais ben ça c'est du jack
3.2 jack deux points non attends je suis
une bêtise jack 3.5 jacques 2.5 c'est
pas les mêmes dimensions de jack en fait
parce que votre connectique on va se
regarder ça c'est elle et où elle est là
elle est là c'est tout petit connectique
donc la cdu 2.5 est ce que je dis pas de
bêtises alors on n'a pas eu l'occasion
de le préciser mais on a la chance
d'avoir notre expert technique jérémy
qui est caché derrière le lait voilà on
a jeremic et au fond qui se manifestent
voyez ces petits bras derrière et jérémy
va vous répondre à toutes vos questions
sur le site de la fnac on en gardera
pour nous quelques unes et puis toutes
les questions qui vont arriver bien
évidemment sur youtube on va y répondre
avec mehdi dans quelques instants donc
je vois qu'il ya pas mal de messages
déjà qu'ils sont arrivés donc de
questions on pose les questions me
demande si le cul c'est 45 et le
meilleur que le 700 tu l'as dit
équipement on va arriver sur les 1 petit
peu différent gardez vraiment vos
questions on va en parler dans quelques
instants on prend un peu le temps de
vous le montrer et puis je sais qu'en
discutant avec vous ça va venir nourrir
des questions et on est là bien
évidemment pour vous répondre mon cher
mais dis donc ça c'est très cool donc tu
me disais sur la sur le sur les
connectiques
wi fi sur les connectiques découpe et
étonnamment j'étais perdue il n'y a pas
de pré revient avec nous mais dit les
connectiques on parle de l'usbc tout à
l'heure pour le chargement à la prise
jack
et si je dis pas de bêtises on est bon
parce qu'après c'est la connexion
bluetooth en 5.1 ouais c'est ça et
on l'état excuses a eu l'occasion de le
connecter à tous alors j'ai déconnecté
et justement je voulais qu'on parle de
qualité sonore parce que c'est
effectivement ce qu'on vient chercher si
on prend un casque s'est pas uniquement
pour faire beau bien qu'il soit beau
c'est pas uniquement pour le confort
bien qu'il soit confortable et surtout
pour profiter d'une expérience musicale
intéressante pour venir écouter et
découvrir donc on parle de signature
sonore bose on est d'accord t'as fait qu
est ce que tu peux me raconter parce que
alors moi je vous le dis en toute
transparence un c'est un cas ce que j'ai
dû récupérer hier ou avant-hier j'ai
commencé à écouter mais j'ai pas eu le
temps d'en faire un test complet un tour
complet donc on est vraiment sûr de la
déco là ce que j'ai écouté la fin
m'intéresse je me rends compte et c'est
souvent les ce que tu viens voir sur un
casque c'est que lorsque tu les écoutes
à différents niveaux bas des fois tu vas
perdre un petit peu de graves où tu vas
récupérer un petit peu trop eh bien je
trouvais ça intéressant que lorsque je
vienne vraiment des ses leçons j'ai
quand même des bases qui sont présents
et sont pas sûr présent ça fonctionne
c'est équilibré et lorsque je le pousse
à ces eaux j'ai trouvé ça aussi super
intéressant de garder ses bases présent
avec un bel équilibre et la clarté au
niveau des médiums aigus lorsque c'est à
la joie gens vrais maîtres mots il est
là c'est celle équilibre en fait
dans l'optimisation qui fait cette
signature sonore ce qui permet d'avoir
d'être plutôt bon sur les sur les graves
les médiums et les aigus il ya cet outil
qui permet d'automatiquement ajusté cet
équilibre en direct hockey et c'est ce
qui participe à cette à cette texture
cette signature sonore après le mieux
enfin parle de son le mieux c'est
toujours de venir se faire sa propre sa
propre idée en essayant en essayant un
casque il y aura pas mieux avec sa
propre musique en général c'est encore
mieux c'est le cas ici c'est un peu
compliqué alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'effectivement ici là vous
pouvez venir vous connecter en bluetooth
5.1 tu me disais alors les codex et du
sbc et du hamas et ouais pas plus pas
moins non plus et si on veut aller plus
loin au niveau de l'expérience et
bientôt venir se brancher en jack donc
ça c'est plutôt pas mal donc si vous
êtes adepte du jack et que vous voulez
expérimenter je pense aujourd'hui la
meilleure qualité sera peut-être
directement au filet ou pour toi on aura
la même qualité en bluetooth aujourd'hui
non la même qualité on aura la même
qualité en alaska et en hockey hyper
canon hyper canon je veux que tu essayes
de c'est très compliqué ce que je vais
demander attention mais dis bien
excentré en concentré si c'est un petit
peu périlleux
toi qui as les responsables marketing
bose comment est-ce que tu arriverais à
me décrire la signature sonore buzz
parce que des casques des marques qui on
existe des tonnes qu'est ce qui
différencie bosse au travers de cette
signature sonore alors bon déjà vous
avez deux minutes
bon courage aux pieds blanche a elle
aussi
désarmant une question extrêmement
difficile parce qu'elle est elle est
allée évidemment très subjective et pour
moi c'est cette clarté on a sur sur les
médiums tout en ayant un très bon
ressenti débats sont personnellement je
je je suis plutôt sur un style de
musique avec des basses assez prononcé
quel style de musique tu écoutes tommy
n'est pas tout révéler mais sauf que si
tu vas pas revenir demain on le sait
très bien des coups de couteau comme
musique alors en parlant d' artistes
j'aime beaucoup par exemple de week end
ouais mais je suis aussi adepte
d'électro donc c'est assez varié et
éclectique de l'éthique ok ça marche pas
avec les mener mais effectivement sur
sur ceux sur ces musiques là sur ce type
de musique je me retrouve assez bien
dans les médiums et dans les basses
après j'aimerais bien par exemple avoir
la vie de quelqu'un qui est plutôt sur
un style rock ouais ça peut ça peut être
un ressenti totalement différent
puisque comme je le disais en fait là
l'aspect qui est plutôt intéressant
c'est qu'il ya cette adaptation en
direct du système du software finalement
qui vient équilibrer
pour pas qu'on ait un ressenti trop
mauvais dans les aigus ou trop mauvais
dans les basses et comment ça marche
c'est une recette maison ça pour venir
équilibrer le système chez soi c'est pas
mon logiciel c'est du software dans
votre cadeau que l'on suit les recettes
il ya des secrets les cas on l'a dis pas
bravo mennea non gelée sévèrement
vulgariser la chose mais les sons sont
captés sont analysés en direct pour
venir en fait tout de suite adapté le
les fins l'equilibre j'ai eu jean pierre
mau mau ouais c'est par leur ton partons
latin mais c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave montrer si tu as un équilibre en
fait ils exactement ok ça marche donc
comment c'est fait techniquement c'est
beaucoup trop technique ok mais c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne en groupe
mais pour autant on arrive à voir cette
signature sonore à différents niveaux
donc ça c'est intéressant alors jeté
posé la question tout à l'heure je te
dis mais qu'est ce qu'il a ce casque à
l'intérieur tu peux me dire les drivers
et compagnie thomas diet peuvent pas
calme toi aurélien sachets bozon dit pas
ses secrets ses silences et la recette
on la raconte pas exactement d'un garde
du corps d'alain gardes du corps il est
la germanie affaire riche et et jérémy
les baraques et donc c'est d'une bêtise
je sais que je vais me prendre les
foudres jeremy derrière donc je joue pas
à ça mais donc c'est vrai c'est vrai que
chez vous il ya cette culture de on ne
dit pas ce qu'à l'intérieur on se rend
compte on profite de l'expérience mais
on vient pas intellectualiser les specs
ouais c'est un peu ça c'est
effectivement laissé un peu savent ce
qui compte ce sont ces de toute manière
c'est l'expérience utilisateur comme je
le disais tout à l'heure il n'y a pas
mieux que d'essayer donc à partir du
moment où on a trouvé un produit qui
nous convient qu'ils restituent le son
sur les sur ses musiques préférées
de la meilleure manière est ce qu'il ya
vraiment finalement besoin d'aller
chercher les specs précise de puissance
de driver etc alors je te dirai non mais
ici alors on est effectivement en même
temps sur le site de la fnac donc ces
bateaux fans que je mets sur ma chaîne
youtube on va venir chercher
effectivement un discours un peu plus tu
écosse donc c'est pour ça que la
question elle elle vient se poser mais
j'ai compris la réponse pas de soucis
alors maintenant il ya un autre point
notamment avec la fnac et une
collaboration avec jane effectivement
super artiste jane on confond parle de
musique donc fait le lien avec jane tu
peux tu peux nous raconter un peu cette
cette collaboration les sens comment ça
se passe déjà c'est une super jolie
histoire parce que premièrement en est
fan on adore ce qu'elle fait c'est une
artiste extrêmement complète je vais
revenir dessus tout à l'heure mais elle
et pas seulement dans la musique elle
c'est aussi une incroyable artiste
peintre et ça nous a semblé
dire presque évident quand on aime quand
on était à la recherche
d'une collaboration musicale d'avoir
jane qui health ont cherché quelqu'un
qui était vraiment très investi dans le
projet hockey et quand on lui en a parlé
elle a immédiatement enfin elle était sa
géniale et elle a immédiatement proposé
ses idées et notamment je parlais du
côté artiste elle nous atteindre
naturellement proposé de venir faire une
création pacifique sur la base de ce
qu'elle ressentait quand elle portait
alors là on parlait des écouteurs que si
airbus qu'ils auraient également à
réduction de bruit donc sacré à sur la
base de ce qu'elle ressentait quand
elles portaient les écouteurs avec la
réduction de bruit donc ça que j'ai
cette sensation d'être enfermé dans une
bulle finalement elle a retranscrit dans
une dans une crise spécifique pour
laquelle on a utilisé cette creham pour
en faire un pack dédié exclusif hockey
intégrant les les écouteurs qc herbays
avec un
chargeur à induction inclus ok pour
retrouver sur fnac.com exactement et le
tout dans une couleur inédite
on peut retrouver que via ce pack après
effectivement jane vient aussi
prêté son image pour d'autres produits
notamment le cul c'est 45 et on est
vraiment ravis de cette collaboration
tout point et on a hâte de faire
découvrir tout ce qu'on a préparé autour
de 7,2 ce baratin tôt lui ment donc il
faut venir jeter un oeil voire les deux
yeux sur fnac.com d'ailleurs le cul
c'est 45 et déjà disponible c est bien
donc s'il vous intéresse si vous êtes
tout de suite là sur fnac.com et bien
vous avez le lien vous cliquez s'il vous
intéresse faites vous plaisir et si vous
êtes sur la chaîne youtube vous avez
également le lien en descriptions
cliquez dessus fnac.com et faites vous
plaisir donc ça c'est intéressant alors
je voudrais qu'on parle de réduction
brute active parce qu'ici effectivement
on se parle d'un casque on se parle de
qualité audio mais aujourd'hui et dans
les usages qu'on a on aime bien des fois
un peu ce coupé du monde par exemple par
prendre l'avion prend le train pour les
franciliens savent avec le rer ça va
être le métro le métro dans d'autres
villes si par exemple je suis dans les
bouchons à marseille je serais heureux
d'abord un casque dès lors que je ne
conduis pas je suis passagers tension va
pas se mettre en danger mais mais mais
tu vois il ya un truc qui est
intéressant sur toute cette notion de
réduction brute estimée séduit quelque
chose de très important vous avez la
technologie je cite c'est la bonne
acoustique noise cancelling est-ce que
l'accent va mal on peut faire mieux ok
alors qu'est ce que tu peux vous
raconter c'est sur cette réduction bull
active alors est ce que tu sais déjà
comment ça marche on parle de réductions
réactive mais finalement ça veut dire
quoi j'aime être que oui tu sais comment
ça marche et que probablement nombre de
personnes qui suit la chaîne
régulièrement le savent aussi mais ça
vaut le coup peut-être de résumé voilà
une vulgaire mans le principe même de
cette réduction de bruit active ok
tu qu'on fasse à 2
face aux pics et récupérer le signal que
vous avez à l'extérieur c'est l'analyse
et c'est le réinjecter ont créé un
système de hors phases et leçons
disparaît du mois tout le son extérieur
la pollution il disparaît on a déjà la
réduction de bruit passive c'est-à-dire
votre casque qui sont vos oreilles bien
vous via vous boucher les oreilles donc
tout l'intérêt d'avoir des coussinets de
qualité qui viennent jouer leur rôle est
bien pour venir bloquer le signal
extérieur et qui ne vient pas et puis
ensuite la réduction de bruit active au
travers des micros que vous allez
pouvoir avoir si je dis pas de bêtises
médiouna quatre micros ici exactement ok
donc on a quatre micros dont qui
viennent capter ici le son extérieur on
annule et vous avez que la musique dans
les oreilles alors extrêmement bien
résumer le tout bravo j'aurais pas dit
mieux je connais mon job tu comptes
là où c'est extrêmement intéressant
c'est que c'est une technologique est
parfaitement maîtrisée par blues plus
simplement parce que buzz en est
l'inventeur si vous qui avez inventé la
réduction bout et c'est effectivement
bosque a remonté la réduction de moitié
c'est beau avec ce qu ses 45 beau c'est
beau
le seul non anglais pour moi c'est
cadeau graal copyright
effectivement avec ce que ces 45 on
vient au delà de la migration du confort
vient améliorer la qualité de la
réduction du bruit par rapport au qu c
35 et même par rapport aux hp 700
puisque j'ai cru voir la question moyens
de passer mais elle va se poser dans
quelles proportions
j'aime bien les questions des touristes
non mais c'est pas une question de si tu
veux c'est loin aujourd'hui je pense que
ça va être pareil pour vous dans le chat
vous êtes consommateur si vous êtes
client de bose vous avez peut-être déjà
allé à cusset 48 6 35 et vous vous dites
altus et 45 pour campagne pourrait faire
de l'oeil mais est ce que ça vaut le
coup de switcher donc que ces 35 à mon
cul c'est 45 parce que je vais avoir une
meilleure de réduction bruit alors au
delà de pouvoir aller en magasin pousser
la porte de la fnac et de l'écouté
comment est ce que toi tu pourrais dire
qu'elle est les meilleurs sauts quelles
proportions alors donnez une proportion
c'est un peu con que jérémy est ce que
tu veux intervenir sur les proportions
propension j'aurais mis à nous donner
de ben ali ne suis même plus le la
réduction de bruit active sur le cul
c'est 45 elle est meilleure dans quelle
proportion par rapport aux puces et 35
tin tin tin tin tin tin tin
ça à mieux isoler les voies nous dit la
petite voix derrière
ouais au niveau des appels surtout
maître capello derrière
voilà c'est en fait il ya un vrai gain
tu dit jérémy au niveau des appels c'est
surtout de ce côté-là
way
vient jérémy lève toi jérémy lève toi
j'aimerais me lève toi un moment faut
arrêter de déconner un sco caisse
comment tu veux qu'on comprenne ce que
tu dis si t'es pas là bien ici jérémy
aulas et le direct vient là on
s'engueulait bonjour je vous présente
jérémy on sentait
qu'il était malaise qu'est ce que tu
fais tu diriges halak ce que tu fais
chez bose je fais plein de trucs pas
d'accord mais parle d'elle chose qu'on
peut dire quand même mon deux roues
ok alors dans quelle proportion ce cul
sec 45 est meilleure au niveau de la
réduction d'objectif par rapport au qu c
35 je veux une réponse précise monsieur
les as et cinq secondes 500 boul on joue
jul et au pascal non alors c'est
vraiment cette réduction de bruit moi je
la trouve meilleur dans le sens où la
joute ces micro là va filtrer davantage
les bruits externes donc ça va on va pas
toutes façons c'est impossible de tout
enlever comme aurait dû comme bruit
autour de nous donc on va on va être sur
quelque chose de plus précis de plus
fins d'accords et du cou
ça va être le mode aussi qu'on va voir
après sur le web et oui votre silence
total c'est là où on va vraiment voir
cette différence est l'ajout de ces
micro aussi va venir renforcer ce défaut
qu'on pouvait avoir et c'est ce qui
était remonté par nos clients où il va
nous manquer justement de pouvoir
discuter dans les transports et que les
gens nous entende clairement quoi donc
et on est très bien les gens mais donc
c'est vraiment au niveau des appels en
fait qui est une vraie amélioration si
vous avez rajouté un micro par rapport
au qu c 35 c'est ça en fait surtout des
micros dédié à la voix haute les autres
voies hockey et du coup forcément on les
utilise aussi dans l'algorithme pour
filtrer le bruit externe et de venir sur
quelque chose de plus précis j'ai
compris merci maître capello allez on se
retrouvait retourner cente scellier qui
vous parle dans le chat de sofac points
comme vous pouvez voir des petites
dédicaces des petits messages à notre
ami jérémy donc on voit effectivement
qu'on a une amélioration mais bon soyons
clairs sur le pouce et 35 on avait déjà
une très bonne réduction de bruit donc
là on vient peaufiner la copie mais bien
évidemment il va pas y avoir révolution
on va se dire tu as qu on est enfermé en
cas plus jamais rien du tout l'extérieur
c'est pas possible ça mais après
mécaniquement avec l'ajout des micros en
plus comme je disais c'est forcément une
amélioration de la réduction de hockey
bon écoute ça c'est hyper canon alors on
en parlait tout à l'heure avec jérémie
on a un autre mode qui s'appelle le mode
away un wiiware ça sera un espèce de
mode transparence donc deux modes qui
coexistent aujourd'hui le mode de
réduction de bruit active donc on coupe
on se coupe de l'extérieur on peut pas
bien module est ce mieux ce mode cette
réduction de bruit il n'y a pas de
différents niveaux il ya un mode
réduction de bruit et un mode
transparence aware il n'y a pas autre
chose c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas la
possibilité de se dire eh bien on va
venir couper l'électronique on va venir
supprimé la réduction de bruit active
mais on n'est pas le mot transparence
vous avez les deux c'est tout pas
d'autre solution exactement ok ça marche
c'est un parti pris intéressant donc on
vous a déjà un petit peu expliqué ça le
mode aware en fait qu'est-ce qui va
venir faire qu'est ce qui va venir
apporter alors la réduction de bruit
c'est très bien maintenant ça vient de
couper des bruits environnants qu'est ce
qui se passe maintenant quand tu as
besoin d'être alerté sur un potentiel
par exemple je suis en live avec toi
chantons pas bah voilà ce qui se passe
et d'orly c'est un événement tant
attendu et entendons sévèrement pousse à
japy soit vous tant attendu retrouve
chez une quiche ou quoi
mais c'est ça je laisse pousser les
attend j'appuie voilà ouvert voilà il
m'a dit omar el mahdi ouvert mais elle
madame m'a dit ouvert exact là je suis
ouvert donc là je peux te parlais que
mon casque sur les oreilles c'est donc
ça vient amplifier certains bruits
droite sur cette fois que tu sois ouvert
un zoom en alerte des deux tons
environnement vrai que ça peut être
utile notamment quand tu traverses la
route oui alors moi j'ai une utilisation
totalement sorti de son contexte moi je
n'utilise par exemple enchaîne les
courses et que je passe à la caisse
pourtant ce qu on dit holmes active le
mode mais mais effectivement je lui fais
ça moi c'est ce que je m'auto coupé mais
alors ça ça amplifie mais pas autant que
si je l'enlève n'ont que récemment
poussé certains sont certains sont ouais
d'accord autres donc tu me dis je suis à
la caisse les monts mode ouvert tu peux
échanger ouais moi je trouve qui a lancé
ces paliers à bosse et c'est toujours du
tout savoir un mode transparent mode
ouvert je trouve que d'un point de vue
purement social c'est uniquement
sociales le fait d'arriver et parler aux
gens comme ça c'est bizarre tu sais pas
s'il ya de la musique tu sais pas c'est
très serré et ça va peut-être venir
c'est bon il faut que moi maintenant
c'est vrai mais en tout cas il ya un
certain nombre de courtoisie à mon
encontre
mais ce que je trouve génial par contre
c'est que et ben comme tu le dit très
justement tu es dans la rue tu te
balades tu te déplaces et ben tu es
attentif aux dangers aux signaux aux
personnes qu'ils feront aimer dit ça va
tu entends et tu peux venir échanger que
cette personne
exactement on a bien résumé le truc
c'est moi je rejoins pas fait mieux bon
j'espère en parallèle de suivre les
questions c'est pas hyper simple parce
que ça il y en a beaucoup qui popent en
même temps donc on va vous répondre on
va essayer aussi de répondre au maximum
on nous parle du aware dans les
répliques cultes de jean claude van
damme c'était autre chose attention on
ne parle pas du même le where mais
effectivement aware c'est être attentif
et c'est tout l'intérêt de ce mode on
est complètement attentif alors je
voudrais maintenant qu'on parle un peu
d'autonomie parce que c'est quelque
chose qui est très important au niveau
de ce casque là
24 heures d'écouté par charge jusqu'à
parce que ça va dépendre bien évidemment
de
2,2 l'utilisation il ya c'est une
médiane qui est calculé en fait si je
vais écouter quoi un volume de 50 % avec
une réduction de bruit active c'est à
peu près qu'avec sa calculette active
d'accord ok et sur une manette wii avec
mais c'est ça on est dans cette
ascension là en termes d'amélioration
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de questions qui
reliera temps revenir par rapport aux
cuisses et 35 ans gagne 4 heures
d'autonomie c'est énorme donc c'est vrai
c'est appréciable et
le chat nommé regard par australe on
sera le chat après parce que vous voulez
tout savoir et je vous comprends mais
y'a un moment on peut pas être au four
et au moulin non mais on part une
question de cession réponse d'ici
quelques instants il nous reste quelques
petits trucs à voir ensemble mais elle
est encore un peu de patience et avec
mehdi on va se faire un plaisir de
répondre à toutes vos questions la
question d'autonomie subit donc on a un
gain d'autonomie on monte à un peu plus
24 heures c'est quand même vachement
bien ouais alors vérifié et testé je
t'invite à soi-même là encore un peu
juste pour les 24 heures mais vérifier
au café et
je sais qu'on a regardé son ensemble au
niveau de la charge rapide ça c'est
quelque chose qui est aussi très
demandés ouais est ce que tu te souviens
combien de temps gelé sous les yeux les
yeux ont glissé dessus la triche mais
oui avec une simple recharge de 15
minutes deux heures et demie des acteurs
2h30 en 15 minutes exactement ça veut
dire que tu dis allez je suis parti je
sais que j'ai un trajet de 2h ou juge
allégeance à rien pour ceux qui habitent
à paris c'est pas pour être pro parisien
mais pour ceux qui habitent à paris une
heure mme métraux c'est banal si on
habite à clermont ferrand comme moi
c'est un peu moins banal déjà il ya pas
le métro on va commencer par là mais
c'est un peu moins banal une heure on se
dit allez vite fait tac je me branche un
petit quart d'heure je vais le temps
d'aller à me faire à mon p'tit déj de me
brosser les dents je suis reparti pour
la journée sans problème c'est ça ça
vachement bien bah c'est quand même cool
c'est très cool moi ça me plaît ça et
une charge complète c'est combien
foule un trou de mémoire deux ans et
demi
deux heures et demie j'ai regardé toutes
vos données
gfr oui cherchez pas à millas j'écris
très malin tout est noté là ok c'est
génial alors moi je voudrais qu'on parle
aussi d'un point très important et qui
fait partie de l'expérience globale ce
qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui et bien
les applications quand pouvoir retrouver
sur un os sur android l'application
s'appelle bonne musique alors est-ce
qu'on peut venir la m attends je te
débarrasser un petit peu sur la caméra
duo est ce que soit on peut prendre mon
téléphone soit le tiens qu'est ce que tu
veux qu'on fasse un mal de chien et l'a
donc d'en profiter le mien hop là c'est
parti je me mets dessus j'attendais du
temps que je me mette dessus j'ai
tellement de choses que
hop là alors je sais pas ce que tu as
déjà fait la configuration est bien
c'est qu'on ne pourra pas voir qu'en
fait la première fois tu les joues et le
configure tu as toute la partie tuto
entre guillemets vb bouton comment
comment le porter et c'est exactement
non je suis dit là il va donc être parce
qu'il est
connecté à un iphone de aurélien voilà
elle vient de me le dire donc je suis
connecté c'est une très bonne chose
voilà tiens regarde
je te laisse faire la manip
alors on va reculer un petit peu ça et
on peut venir zoom et un petit peu
histoire de voile à regarder c'est
magnifique on va baisser un peu la
luminosité aussi si vous me le permettez
sinon achat sur les réglages ouais on y
est ok voilà l'application pour le cul
c'est 45 alors qu est-ce qu on trouve
dans cette application iphone plus en
fait on est sûr simplicité à l'image du
produit donc tu retrouves évidemment
réglage du son au millimètre mouettes et
les deux modes dont on parlait tout à
l'heure
ok donc ici a traduit en si l'ambiance
est attentif chapeau des sujets plus ou
moins aware mais bon je comprends
mais c'est pas mal on peut mettre en
anglais si on veut le web alors on ne
sait pas si on en a déjà parlé de la
connexion multipoint
non je ne fais plus on dit tellement de
choses car la force et plus doivent nous
tous multi points exactement donc ici tu
peux en fait grâce aux multiples
connectés ton casque à 2 apparaît en
simultané et là tu vas donc les sources
bluetooth via le petit bouton ou
bluetooth donc là on est côté sur mon
iphone où on peut se mettre de la même
manière sur n'importe quelle tablette
sur n'importe quel autre appareil
directement bleus sachant pour la partie
conseil me masser toutes les petites
astuces des modes comment contrôler le
son la gestion des appels téléphoniques
les modes on a déjà parlé et la
configuration des assistants vocaux
compatible
l'al roche peut l'utiliser avec siri si
je fais un appui longer syrie qui va se
déclencher sur mon iphone je me google
assistante oui abadou d'alex ah oui donc
on a besoin de tout le monde ouais c'est
le couvert l'essentiel d'un classique
ouais de couvrir le spectre complet ok
ça marche et et voilà
j'aime bien un jeu alors alors de nature
à l'innovation a souligné ya des hubs
d'être régulier sur sur un buzz musique
donc il ya des fonctionnalités qui
peuvent être ajoutés en fonction des
retours clients en fonction de nouvelles
de développement sauveteurs qui peuvent
arriver vous allez souvent le cas c'est
sûr les qcm buzz notamment donc voilà
c'est cela qui est qui peut évoluer dans
le temps elle permet aussi j'ai de gérer
la fonctionnalité simpl simpl think
alors simpl si je voulais entendre
parler dans l'item juste après mais on
va y aller alors simpl think sa 7e ce
plateau qui a voulu dire c'est toi
monsieur beaux-arts
effectivement alors que pour ceux qui
ont la chance d'avoir plusieurs produits
beau chez eux alors c'est un casque
prenons casque accusé 45 mais j'ai
également chez moi une barre de son une
seule barre 300 hockey est en fait le
mode simpl singh permet de connecter les
produits entre si on prend un exemple
concret de la vie je regarde chez moi
avec avec mes potes
un film vrai et pour une raison x ou y
j'ai envie de moi de passer sur mon
casque pendant que lui veut rester sur
la barre de grâce et bien si google sync
permet justement de connecter son casque
à la barre de son époux voir une
utilisation d'un côté casque une
utilisation côté bar de son jeu précise
qu'on n'a pas du coup à éteindre la
barre de son deux pour écouter
simultanément et on peut enfin peut
faire les réglages via l'application
entre le son qui est diffusée sur la
barre de son est celui qui te dire
équilibré pour choisir les niveaux en
fait exactement si génial ça c'est
vachement bien super bien parce qu'on
voit qu'effectivement c'était qu'au
système bose ou les produits vont
pouvoir trouver leur place se compléter
ça c'est super intéressant petit point
sur lequel je souhaitais revenir sur
l'application et tu me parlais notamment
d'évolution et on l'a vu avec d'autres
modèles peut-être on pourrait espérer
l'arrivée de dekwa liseur à l'avenir
c'est un point qui pourrait en tout cas
être intéressant qu'on n'a pas qu'on n'a
pas aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
peut-être la volonté de bosses de se
dire on a notre signature sonore le son
est cette manière là on n'a pas
nécessairement besoin de venir qui
fouillent et l'equalizer parce qu'on
propose la meilleure expérience notre
point de vue alors effectivement j'ai
pas l'information est-ce que les co
leaders va arriver sur les cuisses et 45
ou pas c'est une possibilité ça a déjà
été fait notamment sur le hb 700 ou une
caissière bottes mais oui pourquoi pas
mais le principe est effectivement fait
que avec cette cet équilibre qui est
trouvé naturellement on part du principe
que c'est une fonctionnalité qui n'est
pas nécessaire au tout début entre en
tout cas après suivant le retour des
utilisateurs on reste à l'écouté c'est
une fonctionnalité qui peut être
ajoutées sur l'application mais comme il
est là on a la signature sonore buzz ça
marche très bien soyez rassurés alors je
tiens à le préciser encore sur le site
de la fnac vous avez quelque part par
ici dans le live la petite fiche vous
pouvez aller voir ce produit il est
disponible tarifs le prix conseillé
aujourd'hui ces 349 euros et s'il vous
intéresse et que vous êtes dans le live
via la chaîne youtube vient vous avez
aussi un lien dans la description la
même manière qui vous renverra sur le
site de la fnac d'une manière un peu
général mais dit tu penses que ce
nouveau qc 45 qui doit s'adresser à qui
et bien alors premièrement il ya les
possesseurs de cuisses et 35 ils ont
peut-être depuis un moment et qui
souhaitent passer sur un ami graines de
leurs produits qui restent fidèles à
leur design de par plein de choses déjà
il ya l'aspect
l'as claix rendu visuel qui mine de rien
est important lors d'un achat d'un
casque et le confort qui est procuré par
ce produit une fois de plus je me répète
mais qui est quand même difficile à
trouver ailleurs donc ça s'adresse
premièrement à ce type de clientèle et
on a tout les gens qui sont à la
recherche d'un casque pour tous les
jours avec une situation simple un
casque premium leur permettant d'écouter
leur musique
avec ce fameux son bose de gérer leurs
appels en toute tranquillité et pourquoi
pas s'ils ont d'autres produits à la
maison de pouvoir faire la connexion
entre ces produits là c'est une boule
sync est retenu le truc hein tu vois
alors justement je voulais me dire alors
j'ai un qc et 35 ça fait partie des
questions on va rentrer dans la phase de
questions réponses dont poser toutes vos
questions tout de suite dans le chatt
allez-y on va y répondre enfin surtout
me dit qu'il va y répondre mais en tout
cas on va être tous les deux là dessus
je me dis j'ai un cul c'est un cul c'est
35 il faut que je change par il faut y a
pas nécessité mais je veux changer c'est
pertinent c'est pertinent c'est
pertinent on est sur une amélioration
j'ai presque envie de dire
[Musique]
on est prêt sur le renouvellement de sa
voiture on part sur le nouveau modèle
qui est sorti est-ce que c'est pertinent
oui c'était reconnaissent que c'est
pertinent on bénéficie toutes les
améliorations apportées en gardant
finalement une identité une identité
qu'on aime ouais
donc oui c'est oui c'est pertinent bon
reste est resté avec nous parce que je
vais vous donner des infos il ya un
casque à gagner dans quelques instants
rester bien là on sort pas on va faire
un tour du côté du côté du chat
une question qu'on nous a posé c'est le
puce et 45 at il la meilleure réduction
de bruit du marché c'est compliqué il ya
compteront d une marque mais pour autant
qu'est ce que tu dirais toit par rapport
à ça alors la meilleure réduction de
bruit du marché elle je préfère parler
d'eux parmi les meilleurs du marché
parmi les meilleures du marché
effectivement on a aujourd'hui un marché
qui est un très grand avec des
concurrents qui font également de très
bons produits qui sont positionnées sur
sur la réduction de riz à haut niveau on
est clairement
dans ces eaux-là au caire effectivement
on nous pose une question là sur ma
chaîne youtube on nous dit au niveau
confort avec des lunettes ça donne quoi
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un truc
tout bête mais on n'y pense pas
nécessairement qu'est ce que ça vient
raconter au niveau du confort ton porte
des lunettes alors j'ai passé le test ne
portant pas de lunettes est ce que tu as
des lunettes j'ai palin est ce qu'on a
pu le faire en live en fait va se
trouver des artistes attendus au parc on
retrouve des lunettes
il va je pense que tu vas pouvoir y
répondre
je ferme les yeux
alors non c'est nickel a
très bien pas de points de pression
alors pour autant j'ai pas l'habitude de
porter des lunettes mais je les enlève
un bon dieu mais non non si très très
bien au caire et bien tu veux essayer et
comme ça tu pourras tu pourra répondre
je pense que c'est très intelligent avec
des lunettes on nous pose une question
également qu'elle est la plage de
fréquences mais tout comme le nombre de
driver c'est des choses alors désolé
chante we may niveau confort on et off
faudrait faudra faire le test après des
heures
comme ça effectivement on est au
maintien on maintient confort
une question où on nous paraît
effectivement des fréquences on rentre
dans le côté spex et des choses que vous
ne dites pas ça on va pas pouvoir parler
de fréquences et cette bande de
fréquences et puis en toute transparence
je n'ai même pas le détail des
fréquences personnellement donc oui donc
non voilà la réponse est on ne sait pas
il ya la qualité boss il ya le
savoir-faire de bovins de toute façon on
est sur du premium chez bose il est
évident qu'on a un son de très bonne
qualité maintenant le côté spec pur spec
on l'a pas on nous pose beaucoup la
question de certification ip
beaucoup vu la question qui est passé
donc on est sûr de l'épée x4
concrètement ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'il faut pas le balancer
dans sa piscine par contre que et vite
effectivement ces résistants à la pluie
à la transpiration pas de souci de ce
côté-là mais j'insiste sur le fait on ne
va pas nager avec un nom je vois pas
l'ue la stérilité nommé beauté des fois
il ya des gens qui ont des idées un peu
bizarre
on dirait michael youn avec les lunettes
merci beaucoup très heureux de voir tout
ça merci pour tous vos messages sur des
cessions de 4 5 heures alors je pense
qu'il me manque un petit bout je me vois
là on me dit je n'ai aucune douleur on
parle des lunettes a toujours sur des
cessions de 4 5 heures avec le cul c'est
35 hockey donc on a en a un super
feedback là dessus il ya absolument
aucun problème
on nous pose une question
rivasi est ce qu'ils les rivages
j'arrive plus c'est dur est-ce qu'il est
rivalisent merci et qu'ils aient repose
max alors on n'est pas exactement dans
la même le même positionnement est ce
que c'est des choses qu'on peut venir
comparez pas vraiment forme c'est ça va
être on va dire c'est là la réponse
facile mais on est sur deux catégories
de produits qui est différent qui sont
totalement différent donc en train
casque
il ya 650 euros et laisse on est sur des
gammes totalement différente oui à juin
à nantes là où je pense que toi tu
pourrais avoir un avis plus objectif
qu'elle meure je crois que tu as un air
pas de max oui il est ton ressenti en
fait je ne peux pas répondre au jour de
cette question parce que comme je disais
c'est un casque jet depuis deux jours
que de prime abord et c'est vraiment mon
ressenti un pur jus je prends je fais
assez légers
ont été numéro 2 je prends je devais sur
la tête je fais c'est confortable déjà
tu vois on coche de case je configure je
mets de la musique jeudi c'est bien
s'est équilibrée à faible volume à plus
haut volume la réduction de bruit
fonctionne très bien il ya aucun
problème mais pour autant je pense dans
une phase de test donc je vais pas
pouvoir venir comparer 7 mai spagnola ce
que je peux dire tout de suite et ce qui
est sûr c'est que tout ce que je ne vous
décrire eh bien ils cochent les cases
sans aucun problème on est sur du
premium on est sur un très beau casque
signé bose donc si vous aimez buzz et
que vous connaissez bien évidemment le
savoir faire de la marque on peut y
aller les yeux fermés quand je regardais
les autres questions également qu'on
pourra voir poser votre question que ce
soit sur fnac.com que ce soit sur ma
chaîne youtube toutes les questions sur
le le cul c'est 45 vous pouvez y aller
il ya pas mal de questions au niveau des
couleurs ouais alors effectivement la
sortie comme je le disais il est
disponible on va au serment dire en noir
et en blanc il n'y avait effectivement
sur cuisse et 35 une couleur plutôt
argenté et des couleurs qui étaient
venus s'ajouter au fur et à mesure du
cycle de vie du produit
à l'heure actuelle on est on est tout
juste au lancement il n'est pas exclu
que d'autres couleurs viennent s'ajouter
au fur et à mesure d'accord ok donc on
pourrait voir arriver d'autres couleurs
sur se produira donc vrai ce serait bien
ça
on va le dire ça pourrait être sympa de
savoir quelle couleur sera le plus
attendre justement c'est vrai allez
allez qu'elle avait un bleu un bleu nuit
qui avait été plébiscité ouais ça peut
être intéressant si mais c'est hyper
canon c'est hyper hyper canon alors je
regarde toujours un petit tour dans le
dans lequel bruce ont déjà répondu à
cette question
tac tac tac bon je remonte un petit peu
donc
pas par rapport au qu c 35 mais je pense
qu'on est con con qu'on a vu ça
les différences
[Musique]
non mais écoutez je pense que je pense
qu'on est pas mal je regarde là peut-on
jouer avec temps de latence à ce que tu
as des infos là dessus c'est une
question de david genève plus en tête
j'ai vu la question j'ai démarré en tête
le temps d'attenté était en train de
chercher justement qu'est-ce que jérémy
tu aurais honte est le temps de latence
maître capello
peut-être que peut-être entre temps tu
veux tu pourrais je cherchais le temps
de latence je sais que c'est une info
qui pour le coup est disponible ouais
jérémy jérémy ready aller au boulot
gérer noté on trouve ça on revient sur
la question de la latence dans quelques
instants ont joué non alors par contre
ce n'est pas un casque gaming ce n'est
pas un camion est claire là dessus on
est sur un casque audio et un casque
gaming donc non on nous pose la question
de la durabilité de l'armature alors je
pense que tu vois ça permet de rebondir
sur ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure je
reprends le nom exact un nylon renforcé
à la fibre de verre où la noce comme
résistant aux chocs donc on va éviter de
le jeter partout mais pour autant on a
un casque et résistant ce que j'ai à
dire je pense que l'on va pas se prêter
au test de lancer par terre mais non
mais
bien sûr je peux le refaire mais quand
on voit la façon dont ils se se tord il
se plie en tout c'est quand toute
sécurité ouais oui en terme de
durabilité on n'a pas de soucis on n'a
pas de souci à se faire et tout va bien
est ce qu'il y aura un égaliseur
disponibles ou le monde florian c'est ce
qu'on dit tout à l'heure on en a déjà
parlé mais moi je
pense pas que ce soit exclue maintenant
ça va dépendre des retours utilisateurs
ça c'est déjà arrivé sur d'autres
produits bose donc week end si on nous
pose la question du max de décibels
on n'a pas d'info je comprends la
frustration des gens qui veulent des bdt
cost on veut savoir on veut des chiffres
des chiffres mais là comme ça je ne les
ai pas il ya une pause ne les communique
pas de toute manière bon ok ça marche
je regarde un petit peu les dernières
qui sont les i à poser toutes vos
questions parce qu'on on va on va vous
faire un gros bisou tout à l'heure
withney remplaçable oui effectivement
c'est vrai qu'après un certain temps et
surtout une utilisation quotidienne ça
peut s'abîmer donc oui sont remplaçables
quel type à part de la musique quel type
de média peut-on écouter que ce casque
battre la vidéo youtube par exemple si
on le suit à chaîne merci pour la
réponse
alors comme je le disais alors il ya des
gens qui vont écouter regarder leurs
films en branchant en connectant soit
directement par bluetooth à la télé soit
via simpl singh s'ils ont une barre de
son bose qui fait partie de l'écosystème
qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autres comme média
qu'est ce
je crois que j'ai fait un peu le tour
quand même en vrai le médian fait pas
mal on nous demande d'aller coussiné
sont-ils changeable dans la durée de la
garantie
alors les les scénarii d'avoir la
garantie c'est l'usure en fait
c'est effectivement né sur un on est sûr
de l'usure c'est en fait si on veut
faire ainsi je sais pas comment et dans
quel sens a été posé la question en fait
si c'est est-ce qu'une fois qu'ils sont
usés et qu'on est encore dans les
antilles on peut les remplacer via la
garantie non non non mais c'est comme
comme on achète une voiture et que vous
changez la pneumologue la garantie mais
ils sont ils sont ils sont échangeables
on peut on peut les enlever comment tout
comment tu fais pour les enlever en fait
sur le tu sais où pas trop dit non j'ai
pas fait enfin s'il va passer le test
dessus tire dessus
maître capello maître capello est de
retour vu l'info temps de latence alors
temps de latence pas donné le j'ai plus
le
la mesure en tout cas ouais mais c'est
vrai que c'est ça va être perceptibles
uniquement sur le gaming en fait sans
quelques add à travers les applications
netflix à travers toutes ces
applications et autres pas tous les
nommer je l'a déjà fait on va avoir
cette compensation qui va se faire il y
aura pas de décalage entre le son et
l'image maintenant sur le gameplay passe
quelque chose qui va être plus
perceptible pour pour contrer des parce
qu'il ya une compensation du casque pour
supprimer cette latence et nationales
peuvent à trouver a priori le temps de
latence exacte non d'accord alors pour
le changement des coussinets ici bon
vent non ici allez m capello rien de
plus simple
on tient ça c'est efficace vous voir il
ya les petites encoches ouais
là on voit qu'elle est nickel et une
repositionne facilement de la même année
elle va remettre sur le premier on va
partir sur celui d'en dessous ok et
après il suffit juste de mettre décoché
après l'autre on se laisse aller et tout
va bien je peux simplement j'aime
beaucoup ça c'est ça c'est de la
précision tu vois sachant que sont
fournis des coussinets mais aussi cette
partie là ok donc je vais leur montrer
comme ça hop qui peut se décoller tous
les casques bose il ya deux petits
scotch qui sont fournis d'accord on
recolle au double face on vient et on
repart avec quelque chose ni quelle
était reparti pour des années nickel top
quelle efficacité ce m 4 nages je te
raconte pas jérémy quelle efficacité
bravo merci beaucoup tu peux retourner
sur le merci sur le canapé derrière mais
toi un petit film c'est pour moi ça fait
plaisir
j'aime j'aime j'aime très très cool
alors on regarde les dernières questions
puis on va pas tarder à vous laisser à
part le design les différentes rochus et
45 elle 700
alors que vous êtes tout à l'heure un
peu c'est pour s'adresse pas exactement
la même chose effectivement on est sur
moi j'ai un jeu différent une fois de
plus après il ya cet aspect confort et
le fait qu' il se plie le hb 700 avec
toutes ces qualités ne se plie pas de
cette manière attention ce faisant la
caméra du dessus voilà ses bastions
voilà ça ne perd le set centre permet
pas de faire ça ok
après quelques différences tout
vrai ça va se jouer au niveau des micros
principalement puisque comme je le
disais on est sur une utilisation
plus spécifique pour le 700e on a créé
plus de micro sur le
706 non là par contre la qualité de la
réduction de bruit a été améliorée sur
le 45 par rapport aux 700 hyper canon
hyper hyper canon ok donc on a vu ces
questions là
on me parle de réduction de bruit mais
ça il faut venir essayer également
d'un côté le casque avec un câble jack
quand le casque n'a plus de batterie oui
ok mais on aura enfin bah oui parce que
tu auras forcément à réduction de bruit
tu peux quand même le faire alors tu
peux
ok ça marche à tester c'est intéressant
on nous pose la question par rapport à
nos concurrents le w h 1000 x n 4 de
sony comment est ce que vous vous situez
par rapport à lui alors là pour le coup
on est sûr effectivement une gamme
similaire ok
on est alors vraiment pour le coup il ya
évidemment au delà de l'aspect design on
est sur des normes de confort qui vont
changer puisque en termes de réduction
de bruit on a un tel niveau sur ce
marché en termes de qualité de réduction
de bruit que ça va être difficilement
perceptible entre lequel elle a mieux
voilà donc ça va jouer vraiment sur la
signature sonore blues s'est vraiment
fait jaillir qui est très particulière
wink on aime on n'aime pas appris il ya
quand même beaucoup de gens qui m j'ai
l'impression
mais mais je pense que pour un acheteur
qui se pose la question les l'aspect
signature sonore rendu sonore va jouer
et l'aspect confort quand il va
l'essayer va jouer également on nous
demande et il y reste oui y est la
réponse
ça on a vu tu as répondu le prit alors
le prix on l'a dit c'est
359 euros 349 349 prix de vente
conseillé exactement le donnent les
tarifs en dollars mais nous sommes pas
aux états unis peut-être que c'est aux
états unis l'attention on peut malgré la
nette ont fait de la magie aujourd'hui
donc voilà tak tak que les petons laver
les coups six nations est ce que c'est
quelque chose qu'on ferait peut-être
peut-être avec les microfibres un petit
peu non me faire attention quand même
avec avec la matière mais oui
normalement
futur on peut la fin mais tremblaient
parce que ça on va pas les mettre en
machines non
il ne va pas le mettre en machine
il y at il une pause quand on enlève le
casque
est une reconnaissance du portet ouais
c'est ça c'est ça un capteur à
l'intérieur alors de mémoire oui
d'accord jérémy non entre la mélodie est
donc mal non
c'est sur les successions réunit donc on
l'aura pas là compatible dolby atmos non
autour du cou ou peu de tombes tourner
les côtés coup s'il est alors en fait
autour du cou il se positionne comme ça
et là c'est à l'avant
voilà et là j'aime la musique est parti
et ça c'est bon je vais arrêter j'ai mon
petit bouton on arrête la musique
du raid et disponibilité des pièces
détachées olalala laurent tu nous sors
une question pas piquée des hannetons
les pièces détachées salut c'est dire
combien de temps chez vous alors on est
sur un minimum de trois ans ok mais des
pièces détachées d'accord donc ça ça va
on sait qu'on en a pour le temps sans
aucun problème ok écoutez ça va faire
une petite heure qu'on est ensemble
bravo merci pour toutes ces conditions
il se passe tellement de choses en bonne
compagnie ça va toujours très vite merci
beaucoup mais dix étaient un moment
super super intéressant très intéressant
de découvrir ce nouveau casque signé
bose ou qc 45 et une fois de plus si le
casque vous intéresse vous êtes tout de
suite en train de suivre le live sur le
site de la fnac vous avez la fiche
produit vous y allez et vous pouvez vous
l'acheter parce que vous avez de la
chance il est en vente et de la même
manière si vous suivez sur ma chaîne
youtube vous avez le lien en bas dans la
description et puis hein accrochez-vous
parce que c'est un produit qu'on va
gagner il ya un jeu concours sur le
compte instagram de la fnac tout de
suite là vous pouvez y aller compte
instagram de la fnac pose-t-il au mileu
le jeu tout de suite mais en tout cas ça
ne saurait tarder vous y allez et puis
vous laisser un petit commentaire et
vous dites que vous venez du live par
exemple que vous avez vu mes dix dans le
live vous nous mettez voilà on était
dans le live on était présent on a tous
vu comme ça au moins voyez c'est fou le
support est ce intéressant alors allez-y
sur le compte instagram de la fnac merci
beaucoup mais dis merci à toi merci à
toi merci à notre capello jérémy
bercy merci surtout merci à vous d'avoir
été bien évidemment présent présente
nombreux et nombreuses pour suivre ce
live et pour découvrir ce nouveau qc 45
de bose et une fois de plus je vous le
dis vous avez les filles vous pouvez
cliquer y aller vous faire plaisir le
produit est très sympa à bientôt mehdi a
très bien pour reparler de nouveautés
beau jeu quand tu veux tellement musique
voilà je reprends d'habitation le mot de
la fin il est pour toi
et bah écoute et à très bientôt et une
fois de plus merci pour toutes ces
questions qu'on était vraiment
intéressante on vous embrasse ciao
[Musique]
il